[Musique]
la barbade est réputée pour ses plages
son rhum le calypso
la chanteuse rihanna est un passé
colonial douloureux
le parlement colonialiste dit il présidé
par le roi d'angleterre a statué que les
noirs n'étaient pas des êtres humains
mais un bien une possession voici
l'ancienne villa qui domine toujours une
des plus importante plantation de canne
à sucre du pays
selon l'historien trente mille esclaves
africains hommes femmes et enfants sont
morts dans les champs des plantations
drax à
laruns dit il où le futur roi doit
s'excuser à tous les africains pour ses
crimes contre l'humanité et réparer les
dommages causés par 200 ans d'esclavagé
suivi par 100 ans de suprématie blanche
et d'apartheid le printemps qui
participent aux célébrations marquant la
fin du règne royal à la barbade a plutôt
souligné la résilience extraordinaire du
peuple qui a survécu aux atrocités
épouvantable de l'esclavagé rom des
torts qu'ils taisent
poste
voici celle qui remplace désormais la
reine elizabeth 2 comme chef d'état de
la barbade la nouvelle présidente n'aura
qu'un rôle honorifique
semblable à celui qui était le sien
quand elle était gouverneur général le
pouvoir exécutif demeure concentrée dans
les mains de la première ministre 12
miyamoto vient d'écrire une page
d'histoire elle tenait à le faire pour
donner confiance aux barbadien leur dire
que tout est possible
a dit
la première ministre élu avec près de
73% des suffrages il ya trois ans à
profiter de sa popularité et de
l'effervescence des mouvements
antiracistes pour amener son peuple vers
cette émancipation ya eu au cours des
dernières années des mouvements comme le
mouvement
qui a donc à susciter un désir là par
les barbadiens 2 cm par rapport à
l'accord entre paris
et constitutionnaliste ne crois pas que
l'exemple de la barbade va entraîner
d'autres pays a laissé tomber la règle
comme chef d'état mais l'éventuel décès
d'elizabeth 2 qui à 95 ans pourrait
avoir un effet domino s'il y avait une
volonté du peuple
volonté de la population canadienne
d'abolir la monarchie convaincu les
acteurs pour le tchèque ouvrant moyens
pour le moyen d'appliquer la procédure
de modification personnel pertinents
[Musique]
la barbade célèbre son indépendance en
couronnant une nouvelle reine rihanna
devient la première citoyenne de la
nouvelle république à être honoré la
superstar qui a prouvé que tout était
possible en vendant près de 300 millions
d'albums et nommée ambassadrice d
héroïne nationale